voilà c'est fait le parti québécois a un
nouveau chef jean françois lisée qui l'a
emporté au deuxième tour avec plus de
50% des voix et on a demandé à des
militants de chaque camp au début de la
soirée leurs impressions puis après les
résultats
je me sens fébrile jarre de voir le
résultat et puis peu importe le résultat
moi j'aime rallier on continue on est
content que notre candidat ait gagné
dans l'équipe lisea ton - et puis on
espère que les autres vont se rallier
et puis qu'on va continuer à travailler
tout le monde ensemble je pense que si
alexandre petit lavier notre prochain
chef en oeuvre très bel avenir devant en
raison du résultat notre militant du
camp lüthi s'est abstenu de commentaires
mais muriel a accepté de nous parler et
ses impressions résume assez bien
l'atmosphère qui régnait chez les
militants d'alexandre cloutier
préoccuper plus part par la division par
par le travail qui va être à faire de
d'harmoniser tout ce que je pense
qu'elle peut faire des choses très bien
et je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a un
point de vue qu'un but dans la vie c'est
sûr que je m'attendais pas à ce résultat
là par contre je pense que martin était
une femme qui est qui et forte qui fera
avancer ses idées
peu importe ce qui arrive aux partis le
parti qui est du fonctionnement pour ce
renouveau que ça moi c'est pour ça que
je veux c'est pourquoi il faut qu'on
amène de quoi de nouveau un nouveau
débat d'idées dans le temps au sein de
ce parti à l'épaule c'est vraiment une
victoire
il se fait connaître et a montré qu'il
pouvait d'ailleurs les applaudissements
qui reçoit la salsa pour montrer qu'ils
étaient ivres et manque évident de
perdre 6 e mails avaient tous ménages
ménageant les vieilles chicanes
peut-être aussi non - le parti québécois
peut maintenant regarder de l'avant